Hello, I ca
n't say it. You'll
get separated if you're absent-minded. Come
on in, Kumi-san. You
can't do anything without two brocade tricks.
[Music] It's my
first time in town,
so it's quite unusual. Yes
[Music] The
cherry blossoms around here are also beautiful.  Look, Yuzu, I've
seen it
[Music]
Music From today onwards, you'll grab it
This is Hanatei
[Music] [
Music]
4 minutes
One by one
CT Let's go The
most important thing is the
latest savior
[Music]
me
amaran
uh
ni
me
tan
eeeeeeee
rejet
scenery
san
yanua
[music]
What kind of voice do you have?
Yes, there's a little fox that I want to work at my house. Well, that's
fine. You've been using your head since we've known each other for a long time.  Yo,
Curie, Voca 3. The
castle in the house is empty. Please tell me
a lot of things. My name is Miyazato, and I look forward to hearing from you.
[Music] Let's go and see the
song. Natsu 0. What's that scene? Soma sings.  No,
that's right, I'll leave the rest to Natsume.
Ah, well, Satsuki is that kind of person, so don't worry about it. A
beautiful person. I'll go a
little big and get 30,000 people and take off my clothes. I'm losing
money by choosing.
But my chest is still there.
4th. Next
time, cut it off. Yay.
My kimono 1 has been prepared in the sky. I'm going to have a nice
neckline. AaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaAaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaAaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaI I'm going to go to, I'm going to have a
good time of my kimono 1 of the sky.
If you can be kind to me,
Kakuhari Maezono What are you talking about after this? If you're serious about the four elements of humility,
it's not an auspicious rate.
Thank you. It's time to
get back to work. Isn't this a hot place?
Konohana-tei is a cat town.  Well, since it was created to be the next challenge after God's shrine, this is
our house. We don't
live in a big town or have many people.
[Music] Well, that's how it is.
Deyuzu's teacher, please, Nesatsuki. There's no Sasshi. Leave
that to Karen Natsume. Why ca
n't I increase the number?
Even the talented Satsuki can't do it. I'm
assuming you can't do it. Well, your older sister is by now.  So, I guess he's
bald because of his
job. Yes, Koichi notes.
[Music] Nh, welcome.
Okami is doing well. He's already too energetic, so it would be better to do it early without odor. I understand. It's
early to eat.
Hurry up, you can see the customer
! [Music]
re
me.
Is this the right place for the open-air bath? 2 losses. It's at the
end of this. Please take your time. Slowly. Haa, you're standing right in front of the customer. If a
customer passes by, you'll be on your side.  I understand. It depends on
me.
4th.
2. There are
no sudden group visitors.
[Music] The
cherry blossoms are looking pretty.
8. But if you polish them too much, they'll slip.
Aaaaan. Pixie Shissss. It's past
8 o'clock. No, it's
okay.
[Music] I'm
sorry, but I'll
come to your room later to apologize. I'm
sure it hurt more than you.  It
's Nakai's fault. 3
Then be careful next time. I'm going to go and
apologize on my own. It's
everyone's responsibility.
I am responsible for myself.  I didn't know you, an
individualist, had such a sense of camaraderie, but it's for your own face.From the
customer's perspective, Nakai's failure is seen as a failure for all of them.At some point, you'll
have to quit your job, or at least that's it.  Fulfill your responsibility. There's
no need for an apology when nothing happened. I
erased it, but the young lady wasn't hurt. Yes, it fits her butt.
[Music]
That was a poor thing to do.
Whoa,
use this poultice.  So, are you a medicine lover? Well
then, we'll ask you to get all the medicine, including the poultice. That's how
we feel.
ob Yes, it will be useful for your work, and
medicine will damage your body.
[Music]  There's something
more I'd like to ask you, but I
don't have enough stars, which are the ingredients for this medicine. Could you
give me a few more stars?
Why can't you do that?
You're not just Beito.
[Music]
Beautiful.  However, the customer tried to take a look at it.
[Music] Don't even listen to the
flow. Please just
be quiet. Hey, lol. I tried to do something, but I put it in. It's
fallen on the other side of the house.  Please wait for the evacuation and get in!
Aaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaa Victor, I'm not talking about snakes.
That's called following for fun. Thanks to
both of you, we had a great time.
Thank you.
I'm not responding to your request.
This is medicine.You are a person with a strong sense of responsibility, but you should relax a little more.It
is medicine that will relax your mind.It was
my mistake.No, I just happened to be an
unusual customer.However,
Bigot's  It's true that I was saved in a dangerous situation. It
's a soothing medicine.
[Music] This is my
first time in a hot spring.
4 Bar
Revise. I
once took a bath with someone close to me.  I was
embarrassed.
Satsuke-chan told me that I was not talking about how good it was earlier and the customers were praising me.
ua
I was 5-2.
Nakai was
all one and recognized me as a friend.  That's
why I wanted to do what I could.It was
for my own face.
see Please
come again.
Well, let's go to the other side of the mountain today. I have to go and
pick up the star that you dropped.
If so, I don't know where you're doing it.
Is the star falling there?  You wo
n't know until you see it.
[Music] I'm not here.
[Music]
If you're late for someone's trip every day like this, that's a
wonderful thing.
Mr. Beautiful group, I'm sitting at Konohana-tei these 4 times.  I'm going to do my best with my friends. I
forgot to introduce them later.
Correction: Now, I'm going to do my best.
[Music]
What are you doing?
Just do what you're told. If you don't understand,
first look at it and imitate it.  Even if you don't understand what it means, you're imitating the clock It's been so busy
today You look like you're
tired from the concert You don't have to do everything as I say
Satsuki-chan has a hard time just looking after me, but she's also
doing her job perfectly  That's why I'm a
good girl who doesn't think so that I do
n't want to get into my feet.  Let's team up.
Yuzu's partner is Sakura. Please
be with me.
Sakura-chan from [Music] What should we do next? Asa
Sakura-chan's voice.
Even if you don't understand what it means, if you imitate it, you'll do
well.
Teame
me.
[Music] It's
4 days Soo
yeah
ree
Haa
[Music]
Scholacha Whoa
Yeah
2 [
Music]
Thank you very
much. I'm doing my best to learn my job. I didn't know there
were so many wonderful things.
[Music]  ]
Hmm,
how's the cow? It's the
other way around during lunch break. I don't have to
rush, I don't have to worry.
[Music] Come on, it's okay. I'm with Sakura-chan.
Time passes slowly. It
's because Sakura-chan always finds something fun to do. It's
fun to be with Sakura-chan.  It's fun to have
Hanabi Masho Sakura-chan
[Music] It
seems like the game is up, but I made Sakura-chan, but she's just a Hirot fireworks.
Thank you Sakura-chan, I'll take care of you.
How was your day? Yes, I'm with Sakura-chan.  I feel like the scenery that I was seeing has changed, or rather that I've
only been able to see my surroundings
Well, I wish I
could go to work, but yeah, you both
wore the same hairstyle when you sleep, so
that's fine.  [
Music]
Thank you
[Music] You're a
strange girl. You said it was fun, calling it Sakura. That's
typical of Yuzu. Kiri-chan
said it's
fun, saying it's
Sakura. Rather than fun, it's calming. You don't have to push yourself too hard with the Sakura dance.
Kiri.  I'm so close to Kiri-chan that I'm
going to sleep now, but why are you so energetic?
With your friends
[Music] It
won't turn into something.
Did you mean to do it? If it's boring, then Natsu-onna.  Come to my room. It'll be
fun.
From my private parts. Good night.
1Natural 6
[Music]
Fall asleep [
Music]
Learning is
n't just about increasing your knowledge on your desk.
You're learning about more people.  I'll learn from my heart
[Music] Let's
go
[Music]
Good night [Music]
me
Kitano Kii [
Music]
me
ni [
Music]
ca
aname
ni
Aaaaaa
bon dai
rar
[Music]
me
ani
[Music] It's
right.
Yeah yeah yeah
Levi ah so statue
[music]
yeah
teen
one by one
scene